hallo mein name ist lukan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
folge von minecraft mauer
wir befinden uns hier auf dem minecraft
mount server meine damen und herren
zusammen mit max hey hey ich bin max hey
ich nicht okay dann sorry dann kann ich
doch nicht mit ihr aufnehmen was haben
in der letzten folge gemacht max in der
letzten folge haben wir was sie
eigentlich hier gerade seht gemacht wir
haben uns angefangen unsere kleine aber
feine villa auf den berg zu bauen genau
wir haben uns hier oben quasi unser zelt
aufgeschlagen haben schon ein bisschen
was gebaut hier von wegen minecraft hier
wohnen max und luca und hier oben schon
mal so ein bisschen so holzwaren
hingesetzt ich werde jetzt übrigens mal
einfach live in der aufnahme in andern
shader probieren den maximen nimmt das
ist der shaker den maximal benutzt also
auch dass sie aber auch nicht aus dass
alles ein bisschen farbenfroh stimmt es
auch cool wenn ihr das sehen wollt
könnte bei max vorbeigucken aber ich
glaub ich switche wieder um zu meinem
soll shader so leute wir sind beck mit
sei max was geht
naja das hat schon gesehen so gewählt
dass du da unten sondern so ein ding ins
rein gesetzt da so ein wasserbecken
ich wollte gut erschreckt nicht dass ihr
wisst werk angst haben und nicht dass
ich sterbe oder so aber nein du hast
aber ich wusste dass du nie mich so
verlassen wie ist das laves überhaupt
bot ok max was machen wir es heute in
dieser folge eigentlich für eine
challenge wir machen in der heutigen
folge eine witze challenge das wird
nicht so extrem wie die letzten male mit
wasabi oder eiswürfel oder sonst war
sondern dieses mal machen wir einfach
ein paar witze damit ihr vielleicht
lachen können und das ganze wird ein
bisschen aufgezogenen sinne von trainer
olaf also look also nicht lachen wenn
die witze vorlese aber einfach ein
bisschen fröhlichkeit und ein paar
positive weit verbreitet wie genau wir
hatten ja in den ersten folgen bisher
wirklichen folge eins musste ich
liegestütze und mars machen in folge 2
musste max sich wasabi in den mund
kippen in folge 3 musste ich einen
fitten reinpacken in folge 4 musste max
sich mehrere t shirts übereinander
anziehen das heißt wir hatten immer
sachen wo wir den gegenüber sag ich mal
so ein bisschen gequält haben und
deswegen haben jetzt auf jeden fall
gedacht okay maxis mehrfach ein paar
witze vor ich versuche nicht zu lachen
ich bin eigentlich nicht so anfällig
dafür aber ihr könnt ihr einfach mal
mitmachen und vielleicht ist es ja spaß
ich würde sagen wir beginnen jetzt auch
mal mit einem witz ich war nicht vor ist
es etwas platt hallo wie geht es dir
furchtbar letzte woche starb meine frau
was für eine tragödie was hat sie denn
gehabt ein kleines ladengeschäft und ein
paar tausender auf der bank
[Musik]
ich finde sowas einfach nicht witzig ich
verstehe auch gar nicht
sie hat geld und deshalb hat er sie
umgebracht habe der rat über also ich
war ganz sehr beschäftigt in minecraft
aber hey ich hab da überhaupt nicht
daran gedacht habe überhaupt nicht
verstanden will ich war spitze die
komplette dumme geeignet sind eigentlich
genug was passiert wäre ein keks um die
ecke geht er verkrümelt sich das sind
die edelsten flachwitze es geht gar
nicht klar
also natürlich gerade aber das ist
einfach nur hey das ist so witzig damit
sie hält man sich früher gegen sich auf
pause was macht ein stück unter dem sofa
nicht schweinereien sich für staten
einigermaßen sich fast denken dass dies
gut ja aber der hätte auch so dumm von
uns kommen können
aber ich merke schon diese flachte sind
mehr die flachwitze dein ding als die
normalen witzige ja ich weiß nicht keine
ahnung ich finde so witzig ich habe
vorhin amara witzen gegoogelt weil wir
das erste uns gegenseitig als challenge
machen wollten aber das ist mir einfach
irgendwie aufgefallen dass auch viele
witze die ich gefunden habe so mega lang
sind und ich bin einfach kurz und
knackig sein also ich werde jetzt denke
ich mal wieder zurück zu dir hoch komme
ich habe auch sehr viel holz geholt
haben wir schon irgendeinen weg der uns
direkt nach oben teleportiert quasi nein
wie wir das machen außer mit meiner
katze
mit mein kampf was hast du denn hier vor
unser haus gesetzt sondern bis zum
fußabtreter oder was ist das ja
sozusagen
ich dachte da machen die redaktion
kleinen weg runter so die ausstände das
kann man machen
du bist gerade unten holz abbauen meine
sinne genau ja okay ich habe von hier
oben gerade noch was geholt von
fichtenholz system kann man ja
eigentlich mal so weiter hierüber bauen
also diesen querbalken die mir die ganze
zeit eingesetzt haben dann setzt sich
oben eben noch so ein ding uns drauf ich
habe das gefühl dass hier oben meine
frames nicht zum ultra stabil sind also
ich denke eine aufnahme merkt man als
keinen riesigen unterschied aber ich
muss halt gerade wäre ich halt hier
zocke dass wenn ich hier oben wirklich
auf dem berg bin ist die frames mal so
ein bisschen einbrechen okay also durch
die wände bauen hier eigentlich weckglas
sehr geil ja ich bin dort extra
losgegangen sand zu holen und dann
können wir ins glas brennen also okay da
unten ist auch sein das heißt denke ich
laufe jetzt aber ganz kurz nach unten
und wohl noch sein
da habe ich hab nichts mehr zu essen das
heißt sie machen also was zu essen was
braun klebrig und läuft durch den wald
durch die wüste durch die wüste
ein kamel diese typisch besten witze
dieses frühjahr gab von wegen
was ist was es weiße klopft an ihren
start beim abendessen eine lawine oder
sofa
ich frag mich immer wie die langeweile
müssen leute haben doch so was kommt du
hast gerade den sandweg geholte nicht
erholen wollte heute wir wollten noch
eigentlich gerne also was ich eigentlich
gerne wollte war wären minecraft mal so
ein bisschen auf kommentare eingehen
aber wie gesagt das hier staffel 1 sie
geht es darum dass wir quasi die welt
haben wir haben challenges am start und
irgendwann wenn vielleicht staffel 2
kommen sollte werden was dann auch so
machen dass wir das dann halt immer
aktuell hochladen und ich vor
produzieren sodass sie dann vielleicht
auch eure fragen teilweise mal mit rein
nehmen und vielleicht leute machen wir
das ganze auch mit einem mod pack genau
aber wir haben es ja erst geplant
wirklich mit exit aufzunehmen aber es
wird halt wie gesagt so viel haben jetzt
auch schon sehr häufig gesagt ja genau
das mal rein fähigen schmeißen sie
einfach rein wir müssen uns auf jeden
fall eigentlich noch ein zweites
stockwerk machen und da oben nur die
betten hinstellen findest du die jobs
jetzt eigentlich gut oder findest du
dass er eher schwache starke dort die
robert gerwig gerade aber das einfach
weil ich wenig geschlafen habe ich fand
den ersten jogger mich verstand wohl
auch so hin
ich mache hier unten ein bisschen
kosmetische optimierung dass das nicht
so aussieht als wäre es irgendwie doch
auf was ist braun und dumm heißt mach
was kommt jetzt bakula cius war es das
waren wirklich erwischt was sagt der
große stift zum kleinen stift kenne ich
wachsmalstifte irgendwen witze
königstiger leute das finde ich am aller
kurzen ausläuft auf seiner höhe rausgeht
so raus und ist so alles hell und jetzt
passt nicht alles gerade so langsam
wieder an wenn wir jetzt wieder hier
rein geht dann wird es wieder so ein
bisschen heller aid das ist so geil mit
diesem sheik film von green also ich
baue jetzt quasi gerade hier oben
noch mal so eine plattform so dass wir
wissen dass wir hier oben schlafen
können hier kommt eine treppe hin
hier kommt eine treppe hin das heißt ich
nehme jetzt erde how die hier drunter so
was los ich bin der treppenbau könig max
ich wollte ich jede wand reinziehen ich
sagte das jetzt mal einfach jede wand
reinziehen und jede wand reinziehen
wenn man reinkommt einmal entweder nach
rechts gegen kann unseren kisten und so
oder nach links halt wo wir hier dann
den ganzen stadt haben oder man läuft
quasi geradeaus durch zu unserem balkon
kann man hier nach oben laufen erst mal
ein witz würde ich sagen okay wer ist
das ziemlich geschmacklos vor allem wenn
man hundebesitzer ist was macht ein hund
ohne beine weil sie nicht um die häuser
ziehen dem hause der wcs wirklich böse
soll ich habe jetzt hier unten gerade
die
gerade die teile hingesetzt damit man ja
ich weiß nicht wie man das machen kann
relativ cool obwohl man muss das gar
nicht so machen ich kann ja auch innen
drinnen kann ich auch tolle verbauen
theoretisch ihr merkt schon freunde
heute ist ein bisschen ruhigere folge
wir haben die ersten fünf folgen haben
stück aufgenommen da waren immer sehr
sehr krasse challenges mit am start wo
wir es anpacken ist beispielsweise noch
kalt und deswegen haben jetzt halt
gedacht du diese folge wer zählt einmal
gegenseitig ein paar witzchen das was
wir die wände machen weil wir die ist
halt die frage eines schwarzen können
wir wahrscheinlich machen ist zu dunkel
glaubt also am besten wer was helles
subjekte zum beispiel da vorne gibt es
die birken soll ich mal hingehen und was
holen wirken wir super also so sieht das
ganze gerade aus ich denke ich werde
hier mal die bruchsteine an den seiten
wegnehmen und dann auch noch fichtenholz
hinsetzt damit ich euch schon mal zeigen
in welche richtung das ganze gehen soll
und zwar soll das jetzt hier wieder
vorübergehen hier oben werden wir dann
denke ich schon dass so ein bisschen
zulaufend haben man ich brauche vielmehr
fichtenholz alter ich habe richtig bock
auf das ding fertig zu bauen
natürlich kann man gucken ich bin ja
gerade im wald hier vielleicht gibt es
ja auch fichten heute glaube das ist ein
richten holz mit gerade mal ins all
geflogen dass du höllisch weh max ich
würde aber sagen zum abschluss der folge
und es wird auch gerade nachts mal noch
ein witz raus treffen sich zwei
unsichtbare sagt der eine zum andern
lange nicht gesehen also gott diese
witze die wir jetzt sehen sind einfach
die schlechtesten witze die sie egal ob
max ist jetzt gerade hier zu hause
angekommen bei uns errichtet jetzt
gerade schon die die fenster so ein
bisschen so soll das ganze nämlich dann
aussehen denn man dann quasi zu uns nach
hause kommt läuft man quasi hier so rein
und da kann man sich zu einmal nach
rechts gehen am setzt man ihn wie so ein
paar kisten hin oder man geht halt hier
nach links und dann was wir hier machen
weil sie nicht aber vielleicht kann man
hier auch ein kleines wäldchen noch
hinsetzen irgendwie so wenn man hier so
wasser hin setzt selbstverständlich wird
die nächste folge morgen auf max kanal
online kommen um 18 uhr sowie wie die
täglich jeden tag hochladen und morgen
in der challenge auf max kanal nicht
schon mal so ein bisschen anlässen wird
ekelhaft für und sag ich mal ist mit
einem minecraft challenge aber das
könnte dann ja morgen abdecken so sieht
das ganze jetzt mittlerweile aus max
noch einen kleinen vorsprung gemacht
dass ich auch sehr cool dass wir
vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter
ziehen oder auch nicht aber gucken
natürlich ganz viel wir wollen würde ich
sagen ich hab genug gelagert wenn es
euch gefallen hat lasten like da ich
hoffe ihr feier dieses projekt genauso
sehr wie maxe nicht das feiern hier
findet ihr einen smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr darauf könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren dann verpasste kein video
mehr und ihr findet hier ein weiteres
video eingeblendet dass ich irgendwann
mal gemacht habe und dann sehen wir uns
morgen auf max kanal wieder oder einem
anderen video morgen auf einem kanal